está siendo descrito como uno de los
ataques racistas más mortíferos en la
historia reciente de eeuu lo que comenzó
como un sábado soleado en búfalo nueva
york dio un vuelco cuando un hombre
blanco de 18 años fuertemente armado se
puso a disparar en este supermercado en
un barrio predominantemente negro las
autoridades dicen que el ataque comenzó
en el estacionamiento donde el tirador
mató a varias personas antes de entrar
en la tienda matando a un guardia de
seguridad y luego abriendo fuego contra
los compradores y empleados
me senté allí y luego dos minutos más
tarde oí disparos así que no puedes
sentirte seguro en tu barrio la gente
viene aquí armada para disparar a la
gente esto es ridículo la mayoría de los
muertos son afroamericanos el violento
calvario llegó a su fin cuando la
policía llegó al lugar y el sospechoso
se rindió el criminal portaba una arma
de asalto yo a un chaleco antibalas y un
casco con cámara que la policía dice que
utilizó para retransmitir en vivo el
ataque process wars
hemos sufrido un tiroteo masivo con
múltiples víctimas y varios heridos esta
es la peor pesadilla a la que se puede
enfrentar cualquier comunidad
según los medios de comunicación
estadounidenses los investigadores
también están revisando un manifiesto
supuestamente publicado por el atacante
el documento de 180 páginas asegura que
los americanos blancos están en riesgo
de ser reemplazados por afroamericanos
una ideología conocida como la teoría
del gran reemplazo [__] sí que estamos
investigando este incidente como un
crimen de odio y como un caso de este
mismo violento por motivos raciales
reyna son el sospechoso ha sido
identificado en el tribunal de nueva
york se ha declarado no culpable de
asesinato en primer grado y se enfrenta
a una posible cadena perpetua